[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP j'ai le
grand plaisir d'être dans les Yvelines à
la rencontre d'un artisan qui s'appelle
Richard Dittmer elstrooper et il nous
accueille dans sa ferme en aquaponie
Richard dit merre est trop fort bonjour
Véronique vous allez bien ça va bien
merci nous recevoir chez vous nous
sommes dans un endroit vraiment
particulier
on va expliquer quand même pas mal de
choses alors comment vous qualifiez
votre activité alors moi je dis que je
suis pisciculteur maraîcher d'accord
parce que c'est une façon voilà plus
simple d'expliquer à tout le monde mon
activité qui est double à la fois
l'élevage de poissons et
la production de fruits et légumes oui
mais malaria quand même un petit lien
entre le poisson légumes c'est que les
poissons qui vont faire des déjections
dans l'eau c'est d'éjections vont être
transformées par des bactéries en
engrais pour les plantes de façon
naturelle de façon naturelle c'est des
petites bactéries qui existent partout
dans la nature dans l'air dans l'eau
dans la terre et qui vont transformer
donc
l'azote qui est qui est contenue dans
les déjections des poissons en nitrates
qui est l'engrais principal pour les
plantes c'est ce qui se passe en fait
dans n'importe quelle marque dans une
mare dans la terre aussi c'est voilà pas
de poisson alors il y a pas de poisson
mais la matière organique est décomposée
la même façon donc ouais une petite
marge vous mettez un poisson et hop les
plantes arrivent oui tout à fait et
inversement exactement bah c'est pour ça
que on a des algues dans les dans les
vraiment de capter un maximum de de
clients pour pouvoir cette année se
rémunérer un petit peu alors là derrière
vous moi je vois quatre bassins pour les
poissons d'autres bassins pour le
filtrage de l'eau il y en a d'autres
ailleurs ou tout est là pour les
poissons tout est là
[Musique]
quand est-ce qu'on peut venir acheter
des produits chez vous alors vous pouvez
venir si vous pouvez à la ferme tous les
vendredis soirs de 16h à 18h d'accord
nous organisons un marché de producteur
avec les autres entreprises du site qui
proposent quoi alors des champignons et
des plantes orientales toute l'année
toute l'année moi c'est génial voilà OK
et puis après aussi je fonctionne aussi
en commande
en commande sur le site web donc avec
des livraisons le mardi soir et le
vendredi soir et sinon alors qu'est-ce
que vous nous proposez à la vente nous
proposons des truites arc-en-ciel
entière vidé nous proposons aussi des
fruits et légumes donc au niveau fruit
on est un petit peu cantonné pour
l'instant aux fraises et puis bientôt on
aura quelques autres produits comme la
physalis et après la physalis la
physalis vous savez c'est un petit fruit
qu'on trouve souvent dans les
pâtisseries sur les gâteaux c'est un
petit fruit orange avec des feuilles qui
sont un peu séchées
un petit peu plus goûtu que ce que vous
pouvez trouver en général sur les
pâtisseries parce que c'est cueilli
aventurité et puis localement en général
les fruits voilà pour les fruits pour
les légumes on a des légumes de saison
donc en ce moment on va trouver des
haricots verts bientôt des concombres
bientôt des tomates des poivrons des
aubergines des courgettes des
magnifiques salades voilà des salades
des herbes aromatiques des blettes des
radis on a même essayé des mini carottes
cette année pour pour essayer voilà on
vient de sortir de la période de fin on
vient de sortir de la période hivernale
on a eu des choux-fleurs des chou-aves
voilà et alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas dire qu'une culture maraîchère
en aquaponie n'est pas bio parce que
l'aquaponie ne peut pas être labilisée
bio parce que
il n'y a pas de lien à la en fait dans
le cahier des charges européens de
l'Agriculture Biologique il faut qu'il y
ait un lien à la terre or en aquaponie
il n'y a pas de terre néanmoins on a une
pratique qui sont similaires à
l'agriculture biologique voire limite
meilleur puisque on utilise aucun
engrais ni pesticides chimique on ne
peut pas se permettre d'utiliser un
certain nombre aussi de produits qui
sont utilisés en agriculture biologique
en traitement contre des maladies par
exemple la bouillie bordelaise parce que
en fait tous les produits qu'on pourrait
mettre sur nos cultures ou dans l'eau
pourrais tuer soit les poissons soit les
bactéries ou si on voulait traiter les
poissons avec des antibiotiques contre
certaines maladies mais cette fois-ci
c'est les antibiotiques qui se
retrouvaient dans les produits qu'on
mange l'équilibre et puis c'est surtout
on va manger des plantes qui pourraient
contenir ces antibiotiques donc en fait
on s'interdit tout tout ce type de
produit là voilà alors l'intran c'est
l'eau c'est la nourriture des poissons
voilà on utilise aussi un petit peu
d'algues voilà on fait des compléments
en algue en purin ou en décoction de
plantes naturelles des orties par
exemple la tanaisie on utilise des ce
type de produit qui sont complètement
naturels parce que ben voilà c'est le
système qui nous empêche de faire ça bah
c'est la valeur du système exactement
c'est la première vertu la deuxième
c'est que on économise 90% d'eau par
rapport à l'agriculture conventionnelle
en pleine terre parce que c'est un
circuit fermé donc toute l'eau circule
entre les plantes les bactéries les
poissons et tout le temps et donc il n'y
a pas de rejet dans la nature et quand
on rajoute de l'eau toute l'eau est
utilisée pour la croissance des plantes
et des poissons
et on sait simplement que des petits
compléments d'eau
hebdomadairement parce que Ben les
plantes notamment consomment beaucoup
d'eau pour leur croissance et en plus
elle consomme juste ce dont elles ont
besoin finalement exactement extra pour
vous m'avez parlé de nourriture de
poisson oui et ben je pense là
[Musique]
en fonction de la taille des poissons
donc là on est sur des grosses pour
qu'elles aient 18 mois pour être tué et
déguster en fait c'est surtout la taille
à laquelle on veut les commercialiser
d'accord
22 mois c'est leur dernier instant voilà
c'est ça
votre gentil alors surtout ne vous
approchez pas trop avec la caméra
ils ont faim
à table coucou les filles
[Musique]
il y en a combien il y a à peu près 150
poissons ici
et là voilà ça suffit pour ce matin ah
et ce soir elles auront le dîner
d'accord
[Musique]
voyez les racines des plantes qui qui
poussent dans l'eau directement
[Musique]
ça sent bon regardez si vous goûtez ça
on peut trouver des fraises des bois qui
sont à détails
[Musique]
raisonnable c'est trop bon dans la
nature on trouve plutôt des fraises
comme ça si on en trouve si on en trouve
c'est bien et ici on arrive à toi des
fraises qui sont beaucoup plus grosses
vous voyez donc ça c'est commercialisé
aussi alors oui c'est commercialisé mais
c'est vraiment très petite quantité
parce que c'est
que il faut beaucoup de fraises pour
faire une barquette et donc là on a
vraiment une toute petite production
premier arrivé pour me servir voilà
c'est ça parfait
[Musique]
là on est dans la menthe alors dites moi
Richard avant cette vie là vous étiez
quelqu'un d'autre oui j'étais j'ai
travaillé 17 ans dans l'automobile
j'ai déjà eu plusieurs métiers parce que
j'étais ingénieur dans l'électronique
embarquée puis j'étais contrôleur de
gestion et puis économiste voilà donc
déjà plusieurs métiers et puis ben
ensuite
l'agriculture
mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a sous nos pieds
sous vos pieds en fait faut se rendre
compte que
il y a tout un réseau de tuyaux
souterrains qui permet d'amener l'eau à
aux différents bacs de culture au bac à
un poisson et puis après de collecter
l'eau pour ramener tout ça dans la
Grosse cuve qui va collecter toute l'eau
du système et ça représente 320 mètres
de tranchées et à peu près 1500 mètres
de tuyau
pas entièrement de mes petites mains
heureusement j'ai eu un peu d'aide mais
j'ai tout rebouché de moi-même donc ça a
fait quand même du travail
[Musique]
bon alors on y va
on apprend des mots c'est extra
cerise limite cocktail rouge voilà et
donc le voyez ben là on est l'équipe est
en train de faire l'entretien des plans
de tomates l'équipe nous voici la
première étape que je fais c'est je sais
d'enrouler la tige principale de mon
plan je vais retirer les quelques
feuilles c'est malade c'est malade donc
ils sont plutôt assez âgés
ça permet aussi de ventiler et de
limiter les problèmes fongiques et bien
même s'il est la parcelle j'enlève les
gourmands donc les gourmands sont des
sont des parties des organes de la
plante ils vont se développer à
l'échelle des feuilles et cela on les
retire parce que sinon on va avoir un
plan qui va se développer
considérablement et qui nous dans un
milieu dans un dans un objectif
commercial la pénaliser notre production
en termes de ventilation et de et de
production de la plante et là donc je
vois que c'est un gourmand hop et j'y
vais tac
vous voyez hop là
[Musique]
bon Richard dites mère est trop fort
merci nous avoir accueilli nos ce lieu
unique on a découvert plein de choses
passionnantes on peut retrouver vos
produits donc sur place ou alors à
Viroflay dans une boutique bio ou avec
une association qui s'appelle le
comptoir des potagers
à très bientôt merci merci
[Musique]